[Music]
in our cover story this week kate
andrews asks if the nhs is fit for
purpose she rather suggests not she
joins me now with matthew taylor who's
chief executive of the nhs confederation
now kate um britain's been through a
pandemic we're bracing ourselves for
whatever the consequences are of omicron
variant of course the health service is
going to be stressed and strained
so why do you think that there's
something more fundamentally wrong going
on
well as you say fraser the pandemic has
knocked not only the nhs but essentially
every developed
country's healthcare system throughout
the world so of course it's going to be
more strained it's going to be in a more
difficult
state but the truth is that the idea of
a winter crisis is not unique to coming
out of a pandemic or being in a pandemic
these are the usual headlines that we
would see for the nhs nearly every
winter for quite a long time now the
idea that you would pull the lever to
cancel elective surgeries is also not
new we've been talking about that in the
wake of the pandemic the fact that in
some areas they're being cancelled again
but that happened in 2018 because the
healthcare service could barely cope so
what i'm highlighting in the article for
the magazine this week is that yes every
country has had a very difficult time
with covid and the strains and the extra
demand as more patients who weren't seen
last year coming forward this year is
going to be adding to that burden
although it's an important burden
because those people should be coming
forward but the major difference is that
we have known for decades now when we
look at international comparisons that
the nhs has been struggling it's often
ranked mediocre it is far from the envy
of the world so i think now coming out
of covet hopefully goodness forbid
something should change on that front
this is the time that we need to start
seriously talking about what the other
options are not looking to the usa which
is usually the default nhs versus usa
but looking to the rest of the developed
world that also offers universal access
to healthcare but the emerging data does
seem to be that many of those countries
fared better in the pandemic and are
faring better coming out of the pandemic
matthew taylor when you were working for
tony blair health service was pretty
much half what it is now it's gone from
8.1 percent of gdp to 13 of gdp for
overall health spending if money was
going to be the problem wouldn't we have
the best health service in the world i
suspect even you wouldn't be as bold to
say that we do right now
now i think our health service uh and
there are lots of different ways of
measuring this but it's probably
overall funded slightly less well than
similar uh health services
and it achieves outcomes which vary uh
in some areas they're quite good in
other areas they're not so good
so i think it's important not to
believe that our health services is
perfect or even that it's uh to create a
phrase world beating
to recognize its strengths but also to
recognize that it needs to change but
you know it is very important to
recognize that rising health costs is a
global phenomenon and particularly in
developed countries which have aging
populations because it is indeed the
aging of the population which is the big
driver of health and care costs
i don't think there's anything intrinsic
to our nhs model
universal health care free at the point
of delivery
that i don't think is is is what is
wrong with the health service it's
common to every country pretty much
isn't it every country in the developed
world apart from america is free at the
point of use
yeah i so i i think when we look at what
we need to do with a health service to
get it back on its feet i think first of
all you know it is important to
recognize that between 2010 and 2020 we
had the decade with the lowest growth in
health spending that we've ever seen in
health service history around half
the trend increase in health spending
that you tend to see in countries
because as i say of that aging
population and the consequence of that
was a health service with fewer nurses
per head fewer hospital beds fewer
doctors beheaded than most other
countries like us and a system like that
a system that runs on hot most of the
time is particularly vulnerable to
external shocks and that's why
covid has a had a particularly uh
challenging effect uh on our population
and on our health service right
figure i quoted 13 of gdp that's higher
than any country in europe any country
in the world except the united states i
mean you cannot really say that britain
lacks for health spending because we
literally spend more as a share of our
economy than anybody else beside the u.s
i think if you look at public health
spending we rank below the average in
the eu 14 we're just about average for
the oecd so you can look at this from
various perspectives is it public
spending is it private expecting
spending is it is it total spending i
don't
you know in in a sense
the question of of as it were this could
existential question of whether or not
the health service works
i'm not sure where it takes us there is
no public appetite for
changing the core principles of the
health service any attempt to do that
would be massively disruptive which is
the last thing that we need now i think
instead we need to focus on the
practical challenges that the health
service faces and also and this is
critical the opportunities which are
going to be provided by digital by data
by medtech
those offer the opportunity to make a
real difference to our health service in
the coming years and i think that
that's really the thing we should focus
on how can the health service take
advantage of those shifts to achieve a
step change in the quality of its
service
so kate the health service is reasonably
funded and is doing a reasonable job
well look i think we can measure health
care spending in all kinds of ways but a
percentage of gdp spent on on health
care has often been the way that people
look at it and one of the reasons is
because if you go back say a decade the
nhs was relatively average in the oecd
so that was a convenient metric to say
that the issue is more money we need
more funding that's always the go to
whenever the nhs has a problem we simply
say we need more funding now this has
changed quite radically and recently
because boris johnson after putting nhs
pledges on the side of a brexit bus has
really decided to double down on that
try to make the tories the party of the
nhs and so far he's not doing that with
reform he's he's doing that with money
but in 2020 the metric that is so
frequently used to look at healthcare
spending does put the uk
second highest in all of the oecd so
those countries that are often cited for
having better funding germany
switzerland france that also get better
outcomes have have fallen behind the nhs
on that metric and if we look between
2010 and what we estimate by 2025
the health care budget the nhs budget
will have gone up by 42 percent and i
think if we look at something like
schools it's roughly three percent
in the next election the day-to-day
public service spending is going to be
roughly 44
of the whole budget we're getting quite
close to having a health care service
with a government attached and i think
it's very important crucial that in
these next few years given the fact that
we have the system we do we focus on
getting those resources to the front
lines and to supporting the doctors and
nurses who are trying to help patients
but we cannot keep funneling money into
what is so clearly a broken system and
the money that we were spending in 2020
just doesn't seem to on the preliminary
data have gotten us the outcomes we
wouldn't have wanted let's go back to
lockdown last year look at the oncology
appointments for cancer patients in
germany they dropped by 33 that's a
stark figure but in the uk they dropped
by 60
if you look at swedish breast cancer
patients uh the those that were being
seen dropped by 10 in the uk it was 30
with the money we were spending last
year alone we should be doing better on
these metrics so in the next few years
yes by all means let's try to be
efficient but we clearly have more to
learn from other systems and i think we
need to stop being so blinded as to what
they're doing right because as matthew
says that that principle of universal
access to health care is so deeply
important but for the person waiting for
their ambulance to show up who's losing
hope or for the person who still can't
see their gp
you know free at the point of use is
losing its relevance the nhs is not
there for them and surely that is really
the point to get people access to care
matthew what do you make of that point
then that's non-coveted care during the
pandemic was far worse hit in britain
than it was in other countries i mean
kate said the cancer care for example
took a way bigger hit here than it did
in sweden if you look at knee operations
hip operations they went down far more
here by about 45 50 percent than they
did in ireland and italy where they went
down by about half of that level so why
is it in denmark they actually went up
so why is it other countries are able to
carry on their non-coded care when in
britain we've seen that knocked for six
and a waiting list of something like 5.6
million people
so this is why it seems to me that bold
statements like you know the nhs is
broken the nhs doesn't work it doesn't
really get us anywhere you know it's a
it's it's kind of a level of generality
which is fine for political posturing
but no good when it comes to actually
practical steps so why well the simple
reason is the way in which we run our
health service uh has been to minimize
the number of beds
statistics are all over the place at the
moment because of kobe but one thing
that was pretty commonly seen about our
health service was that it was a you
know a pretty efficient health service
even if some of its outcomes were were
not what we would want them to be
if you talked to
doctors even before covid
and you talked about the the occupancy
rates we had in hospitals in the summer
people in other countries continentally
would be amazed that we would occupancy
rates between 80 80 percent plus in the
summer when
uh you know in other countries this
would have been unheard of people would
be taking holidays things would be
there'd be a lot of of give in the
system that's not how we want things we
run things so that you know we do have
uh difficult winters every winter we do
get people out hospitals
we do have high quality rates so when a
crisis like covid happens there is no
slack in the system that's the way that
our system has been uh designed that's
right is that a good thing do you think
i mean it sounds to me like a pretty bad
thing that we run it bad for a doctor
it's bad for patients every winter we
seem to be in a crisis i mean surely
there must be a better way of going to
europe it doesn't happen to the same
degree now you're saying yes it's
efficient if you look at the proportion
of beds that are filled but that seems
to be a rather strange way of defining
efficiency if you define it for for
patient care for example if you define
it in terms of patient outcomes surely
that's way more efficient than what
proportion of the beds are filled and
isn't it the nhs way of doing it
maximizing the bed occupancy rationing
health care hasn't that become the
problem
so i think if you look at the way in
which the nhs has been resourced over
the last few years one of the problems
has been feast and famine you know we
saw a lot of extra money going under new
labor i think looking back
not as much reform not as much progress
should have been made a lot was made you
know by the time labour left office we
were meeting those key targets for
waiting lists emergency departments
elective care making real progress
we then move into these 10 years of
austerity with spending increasing at
less than half the
you know annual global increase in
developed countries you expect in the
health service
what that has led to
is major capacity issues we have major
capacity issues in terms of the capital
of the health you know the health
service you know hospitals in a very
poor state of repair not made the
investment we should have made in areas
like digital and of course the number
one problem right now which is workforce
you know we did not plan sufficiently we
did not invest efficiently and now
actually we've got a situation health
service where where in the short term at
least there is the cash but people don't
know how to spend it because we don't
have the workforce because it takes
several years to put that workforce in
place and yet even now
we are pressing the government to
publish more regular
workforce plans and there's a push back
against that why is there a push back
against that because if you publish
workforce plans for the health service
it comes with a price tag attached and
the government does not want to see that
price tag in the public domain
so it isn't just about the level of
resource unfortunately we've gone
through this feast and famine and that
has left us in the position when kovitz
struck where where our capacity in areas
like capital in areas like workforce was
not where it needed to be and we've
suffered as a consequence so kate
andrews and matthew taylor is saying it
comes back to resources there there was
not much tourist but there was not much
health spending during the austerity
years we're now looking at the
consequences of that decision to slow
down and not exactly cut but slow down
on nhs spending when we should have been
investing the result the disaster that
we see now
well to be very clear the nhs budget was
going up in real terms every year it was
just that it was going up perhaps less
than others would have liked to see it
go up and i think a lot of this also
comes down to priority about where the
money that has been funneled in actually
went to whether or not it went to
management or whether or not it went to
the front line it's very clear that some
of those priorities were perhaps in the
wrong order um you know i think
matthew's highlighted very well that
this is a system that is intentionally
designed to run hot the way you argue
you are efficient is to not have spare
capacity to not have spare beds to not
have spare workers to always be
operating on the brink and i think covet
highlighted a lot of things number one
do you want a health care system that
does that but number two
with the nhs logo being used to convince
people to stay home you know protect the
nhs as i mentioned in an article a
senior source um on the health side on
the nhs side said you know test and
trace had nothing to do with us they
wanted to use that nhs logo because it's
so powerful that kept a lot of people
home now they're coming back the demand
is rising i still don't think the
resources are in the right place but
this should make us question overall
whether or not this is the kind of
system that we can live with for the
next pandemic because whether if our
freedoms are really tied to nhs capacity
it's going to be a rough life
for for all of us in the coming years
because as i mentioned at the beginning
nhs capacity is an issue every winter
not just with covet then after that i
think you have to go back frankly
decades look at these international
comparisons and while we are all quite
rightly talking about the value of life
and what we all did on and off for the
past two years to protect life to to to
to respect individual life we need to
look at the fact that if cancer patients
were treated in other countries from
four of the most common types of cancer
in say germany or say belgium thousands
more lives a year could potentially be
saved in short the system really does
matter so this is a time if you really
want to protect that that principle of
universal access to health care if you
want more resources for the nhs if you
would like to see it better funded but
for those for and it is going to be
better funded from next year with the
health and social care levy if you
actually want to see that money put to
good use you have to address the system
and that's going to have to come from
whitehall from the people in charge and
they're going to have to be courageous
because for a very long time politicians
simply have not been able to criticize
the healthcare service it has become a
national religion but it is one that is
not doing us any good
[Music]
you